dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Olathe here and it is
time for some mind to be blown we're
going to talk about a philosophy paper
before we start a quick definition an
ancestor simulation is a hypothetical
computer simulation that is detailed
enough that the entities living within
our conscious imagine a computer game
that you play that doesn't contain mere
digital characters but fully conscious
beings with feelings aspirations and
memories there are many interesting
debates among philosophers on crazy
elusive topics like proved to me that
I'm not in a dream or I'm not just a
brain in a bottle somewhere that is
being fed sensory inputs well good luck
in his paper Nick Bostrom philosopher
offers us a refreshing take on this
topic and argues that at least one of
these three propositions is true almost
all advanced civilizations go extinct
before achieving technological maturity
there is a strong convergence among
technologically mature civilizations in
that none of them are interested in
creating ancestor simulations and here's
the bomb we are living in a simulation
at least one of these propositions is
true so if you say no to the first two
then the third is automatically true you
cannot categorically reject all three of
these because if two are false then the
third follows also the theory doesn't
tell which of the three is true let's
talk briefly about the first one the
argument is not that we go extinct
before being technologically advanced
enough to create such simulations it
means that all civilizations do this is
a very sad case and even though there is
research on the fact that war is
receding there's a clear trend that we
have less warfare than we've had
hundreds of years ago have linked a
video on this here from course cos act
it is still possible that humanity
eradicate itself before reaching
technological maturity we have an even
more powerful argument that maybe all
civilizations do such a crazy
proposition
second point all technological immature
civilizations categorically reject
ancestor simulations maybe they have
laws against it because it's too cruel
and unethical to play with sentient
beings but the fact that there is not
one person in any civilization in any
age who creates such a simulation not
one criminal mastermind anywhere ever
this also sounds pretty crazy and if
none of these are true then there is at
least one civilization that can run a
stupendously large number of ancestor
simulations the future nerd guy just
goes home grabs a beer starts his
computer in the basement and fires up
not a simple computer game but a
complete universe if so then there are
many more simulated universes than real
ones and then with a really large
probability where one of the simulated
ones Richard Dawkins says that if this
is the case we have a really disciplined
nerd guy because the laws of physics are
not changing at the whim we have no
experience of everyone suddenly being
able to fly and as the closing words of
the paper states with graceful eloquence
in the dark forests of our current
ignorance
it seems sensible to apportion ones
credence roughly evenly between 1 2 & 3
please note that this discussion is a
slightly simplified version of the
manuscript so it's definitely worth
reading the paper if you're interested
give it a go as always I've put a link
in the description box there is no
conclusion here no one really knows what
the answer is this is open to debate and
this is what makes it super interesting
and now my personal opinion it's just an
opinion it may not be true it may not
make sense and may not even matter
just my opinion I'd go with the second
the reason for that is that we already
have artificial neural networks that
outperform humans on some tasks they are
still not generally enough which means
that they are good at doing something
like the deep blue is good at chess but
it's not really useful for anything else
however the algorithms are getting more
and more general and the number of
neurons that are being simulated on a
graphical card in your computer are
doubling every few years they will soon
be able to simulate so
more connections than we have and I feel
that creating an artificial super
intelligent being should be possible in
the future that is so potent that it
makes the universe simulation pale in
comparison what such a thing could be
capable of hmm it's already getting too
long I just can't help myself you know
what let's discuss it in a future two
minute papers episode and love to hear
what you fellow scholars think about
these things if you feel like it please
leave your thoughts in the comment
section below I'd love to read it
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time